When I got asked to make a magazine cover from scratch,
I obviously had to say yes.
So welcome, ladies and gentlemen,
to my first who what wear?
Cover shoot. Weeks before this,
I came up with the mood board,
the concept, the wardrobe,
hair and makeup references,
nail references. After the team put together all the mood boards,
I approved them, then got on a plane to LA to shoot this cover.
Knew that having a really good glam team was so important to me,
so I only picked people I trusted,
and obviously, whimsy Lewis,
part of that team. First thing we did was film a YouTube video
where I got to try all the viral Erewhon smoothies
and definitely had my opinions on it
before doing a quick outfit change and heading downstairs to shoot.
Started off with this leopard look and the cutest cat
before changing into this Gucci gown was the most stunning thing,
and it definitely made me feel like a completely different person.
This point, I was so hungry,
so I had some lunch while Chris chopped off my hair
and changed into one of the two looks that we were doing.
This particular haircut,
and it was time for a complete hair and makeup transformation.
My inspo for this was Bridget Bardell.
While we were doing this, my Scaparelli look came in,
and it was a workout for every single one involved,
but so worth it to get the shot.
After getting The cover. Whimsy
and I went outside to watch the sunset
before changing into the last look of the day.
This whole experience was so much fun,
and I can't wait for you to see the cover
and read my very honest interview.